et on en parle avec vous maurice lemoine
de cette journaliste spécialiste de
l'amérique latine ancien rédacteur en
chef du monde diplomatique merci d'être
avec nous alors est-ce qu'il ya eu
fraude en bolivie lors des élections
présidentielles et dernières élections
présidentielles vous venez de le
mentionner le 28 août en poste il ya
deux jours de 26 ans le 26 a publié des
résultats d'une investigation du
prestigieux et mighty un institut de
technologie du massachusetts dans lequel
deux chargeurs 10 qui a pas eu de fraude
il avait déjà vu un certain nombre
d'organismes qui avait fait le même
constat en particulier le cep est
requêtes insistantes de washington
dire qu'en réalité il ya eu evo morales
on le sait maintenant que c'est depuis
longtemps mais et est arrivé en tête de
ces élections il avait gagné l'élection
et il a eu en bolivie un coup d'état de
l'état réel de la situatio riz l'étude
j'aime haïti ces sables à écouter sur un
spécialiste du vin d'humanité mais enfin
d'une manière générale il respectait
dire c'est pas un organisme gauchisant
c'est pas un organisme sur lequel on a
une suspicion c'est par ailleurs un
organisme américain états unis il n'y a
pas de raison de suspecter une
quelconque connivence avec evo morales
il ya des élections générales qui
doivent se tenir le 3 mai le tribunal
suprême électoral donc bolivien interdit
à evo morales de s'y présenter
lui pourrait saisir justement la cour
interaméricaine des droits de l'homme en
tout cas c'est ce que ses avocats lui
conseille est-ce qu'il a véritablement
un recours aujourd'hui pour changer la
donne et pourquoi pas revenir dans le
jeu politique en bolivie alors une
grosse difficulté c'est que il ya deux
interdictions en fait d'emblée grâce à
l'action de l'organisation des états
américains dont il faut rappeler que le
secrétaire général qui s'appelle luis
almagro est un authentique mercenaires
de donald trump a invité c'est un homme
lige de donald trump
raison pour laquelle le or à manipuler
de l'élection bolivie je n'hésite pas à
dire
donc on a interdit à evo morales se
représenter à la présidence il ya donc
un binôme qui a été qui a été désigné
par les mouvements sociaux qui se
présentera
et par ailleurs on a interdit à evo
morales de se présenter au sénat en
arguant du fait que il est une vie pas
en bolivie qui ne vit pas dans sa région
de cochabamba mais qu'il vit qui lui en
argentine alors bien évidemment il est
en argentine mais l'étonnant fantine
parce qu'il a été poussé à la démission
et que y compris il s'est exilé d'abord
au mexique ensuite en argentine
essentiellement pour assurer sa sécurité
donc l'argument en réalité si on prend
en termes de droit ne tient pas mais
justement pour evo morales et c'était
plus important à votre avis aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est de revenir comme jeudi
dans le jeu politique ou bien justement
ces 2 2
d'effacer justement les suspicions de
fraudes qui ont entaché les dernières
élections alors mal sur le terme de
suspicion de fraude je ne le partage pas
vous l'avez vous l'avez compris il n'y a
pas eu fraude il ya eu plus avoir des
irrégularités il n'y a pas eu fraude
chez maintenant à tester par un certain
nombre d'organismes evo morales
lorsqu'on regarde la bolivie le
mouvement vers le socialisme selon son
parti
en fait c'est un mouvement de mouvement
et c'est l'homme qui réussit à coaguler
tous ces mouvements semblent raison pour
laquelle le mas depuis 14 ans a gouverné
la bolivie
il a été nommé par c par le match est de
campagne bien qu'étant il ya un candidat
qui est désigné à sa place bien sûr et
donc ses mouvements avec evo morales ont
désigné comme candidat
luis aramcheck et l'ancien ministre des
finances d'evo morales et david
choquehuanca qui a été soumise affaires
étrangères donc c'est bien une
représentation du mas qui va se
présenter à la présidentielle mais evo
morales demeure l'homme important il
faut pas faire des comparaisons
imbéciles mais on parle encore en france
du général de gaulle le venezuela c'est
hugo chavez en bolivie evo morales c'est
lui qui a transformé ce pays c'est lui
qui a assuré une une stabilité au pays
pendant 14 ans y compris avec la qui a
sorti de la marginalisation des
populations indigènes qui sont la
majorité en bolivie donc il a un rôle
symbolique extrêmement important et il
le sait cela étant lorsqu'il a
démissionné poussé par l'armée est avec
une révolte de la police nous le pousser
et alors que des proches et des députés
étaient pris en otage par les les
secteurs n'est plus les plus fascinants
de ce coup d'état
il l'a fait pour éviter un bain de sang
en libye c'est à dire qu'il a un sens de
la responsabilité
il appuie la décision qui de son point
de vue s'impose elle s'imposait pour
éviter une catastrophe à la bolivie
mais il demeure une référence
incontestable dans son son avenir
puisqu'il est directeur de campagne
aujourd'hui du candidat de
il a été donc investi par son parti pour
la prochaine présidentielle
il a encore un post la clé qui peut le
mener
de toute façon dans les sphères du
pouvoir si il ya deux semaines allait
s'imposer
il ya deux solutions aussi ce que
j'appelle des putschistes bolivien
réussissent à empêcher le mas de gagner
l'élection présidentielle parce que la
question qui se pose c'est est ce que
cette élection va avoir lieu dans des
conditions régulières
or il n'y a absolument aucune garantie
puisqu'elles vont être supervisés lower
qui elle-même a participé au
renversement d'evo morales
on n'a aucune garantie si parce que je
vais appeler la droite au sens large
revient au pouvoir il est évident qu evo
morales va demeurer en exil puisqu'il
est sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
pour terrorisme sédition ce qui est une
absurdité
il a des soutiens l'échelle
internationale est vraiment à l'aise
malheureusement pas beaucoup
malheureusement pas beaucoup y compris
il faut il faut il faut souligner le
rôle honteux de l'union européenne et y
compris de la france qui lorsque janil
agnès la présidente autoproclamé a pris
le pouvoir le vin le vin le 20 novembre
le 22 vous avez 23 ambassadeurs dont
l'ambassadeur de l'union européenne
l'ambassadeur de france qui sont venus
la saluer c'est un véritable scandale
c'est un véritable scandale est ce qu
est un désastre un naufrage pour la
diplomatie française entre parenthèses
merci beaucoup à vous maryse et moi je
rappelle qu'on est journaliste
spécialiste de l'amérique latine ancien
rédacteur en chef du monde diplomatique
merci